Felix Rodriguez author of Shadow Warrior
the CIA hero of a hundred unknown
battles let me read you one sentence
from page 65 and get your reaction I
volunteered to assassinate Fidel Castro
and the Americans took me up on it why'd
you write that well it was in 1960 when
we were in the training camps in
actually we were in Panama then for
final training before the Bay of Pigs
like a friend of mine I this cost than
we thought I would shorten the war in
Cuba Fidel worth digging out so we we
call our case officer at that time in
the area Panama where we were we
volunteer to to kill Fidel we were at
that time about nineteen years old then
how close did you get
well we were given a rifle with a
telescopic sight and we were three times
we attempted to infiltrate Cuba we say
both that had a Ukrainian crew on it
plus an American captain
and we went twice close to the coastline
and the boat who were supposed to meet
us never arrived and so on the third
time after the third time we returned it
they told us that the plan had been
changed have been canceled so they took
the rifle away they added two more
members Cubans to my team and we working
as a member of the infiltration team for
Las Vegas problems didn't give it any
second thought to kill another human
being well if you have seen how many
people feel they'll have killed how many
of our friend is a summated it's a it's
a different perspective the different
situation we don't believe that a
government should be involved in that
but at the same time like the same
people I be Israeli or not Israeli the
Jewish people you tell them the Hitler
were alive I think there would be a lot
of people trying to get him I guess the
same a similar situation with the Cubans
have you known a lot of people in your
life that have said the same thing that
they'd be glad to kill Fidel Castro yes
many how come no one's ever gotten the
job done some have tried if you they'll
have a very very good security system in
the past that is Czechoslovakian who's
wrong who's he who run his security
force he moved from one place to the
other for example when he was in Havana
I saw him moving
in near the malecon area with five
bulletproof mercedes all exactly the
same with the same antennas you could
not tell one from the other and he live
right at either in number two of the
number four in between so you never know
which one of the five car he was going
to be it was very hard to get him what
happened when he no longer is in power I
think it's going to be a tremendous a
power struggle inside Cuba
I still believe that it will happen
pretty soon there is a lot of product
right now between him and his brother
Raul is trying to get these power or
being a position to seize power if
anything happened to Fidel and there is
a lot of problems in my opinion between
Raul group and other groups in the Cuban
military that we have seen for example
the the execution of general ashore
which was from a different group the
group of Q and generals who were in
Africa that Cuban journalists are
wearing Angola in Ethiopia in Nicaragua
and the other group they are just friend
to Raul Castro which is not part of that
elite corps and there is a lot of
problems in among both group between
both group in there today
tell us your status or in American
citizen yes I am how long have you been
one since 1969 how long did you serve it
shoot me in the US military well after
the Bay of Pigs
President Kennedy gave a commission to
the officers in the brigade to be a
member of the Armed Forces of the United
States I was giving a Presidential
Commission as a second lieutenant in the
Army in Fort Benning Georgia
I only resigned because molarity me who
was the civilian leader of the brigade
came to me at that time in in Fort
Benning Georgia and told me that the
president has personally authorizing
operation to overthrow Fidel and thus I
believe also go closely with the fact
that President Kennedy was assassinated
I believe very strongly that Fidel gang
was behind that after President
Kennedy's failure with the Bay of Pigs
he got all the Cubans out of prison who
bringing the word captured during the
Bay of Pigs and in the Orange Bowl in
Miami he gathered with all of them after
they were put out of Cuba and promised
to return the brigade flag in a free
Havana and after that he took deadly
sure to that effect he gave us
commissioning the Armed Forces and then
he started and organized in a special
operation out of Nicaragua where I was a
participant for the matter of fact at
that point in time I specifically asked
proof that the u.s. government was
involved in that operation against Fidel
and say what do you need and say well if
you wanted me to take a special
communication training I like to have it
in uniform even though it has nothing to
do with the army and they say ok no
problem and sure enough a few weeks
later mr. moose and mr. Flannagan showed
up in Fort Benning Georgia and I was
given a special training for
communication for that project that was
sponsored by the President of the United
States and three of us resigned to the
our Commission to participating there so
how long where do you live now
yummy how big is your family well I have
a song a daughter and my wife my father
is still alive and where do you work now
well I am retired from the agency's 1976
but I have continued to support like
when I went to El Salvador back in 1985
when there is a volunteer to help the
Salvadorian government with the
helicopter comes said that I knew was
going to be a valid operation and proved
to be so we were able to capture in our
first operation on the 18 of April 1985
media DSD commander who happens to be
also the commander from the PRT see that
were the unit who assassinated the
Marines later on we capture her and she
was later exchanged by President large
daughter and media diat now live in
Havana so it was it was a very valid
belief concept which proved to be very
effective in El Salvador
he said you retired from the agency what
agency CIA in 1976 how long did you work
for it oh I work since 1960 I say
calling off a few times like when I
going to the army I left it and then
back again can you afford to live now or
that I mean do you have it you have a
means of income besides yes I have my
retirement that I received and also my
wife work the University of Miami Barry
University Miami so the audience what
this book looks like and it's brand new
it's called Shadow Warrior the CIA you
can see
here is another name down here and it's
John Weissman who's he he's the
co-author of the book and actually he's
the man responsible to a great extent
for the book oh he was the one who
convinced me to write my autobiography
why did he care
well I he sold me testifying Congress
and at the beginning he told me that he
thought it was a great novel and then he
went back and he thought it was a very
good story to tell and he finally got
through for a common sprain that we had
to be in convinced me or it took him a
lot about six months to convince me to
write the book and I think one of the
factors that contributed quite bed to
that was these SS see the quality factor
contributed most of that was what I had
to go through and my family had to go
through with Senator Kerry's committee
and I thought it was a good idea then to
write the book and set the record
straight on that account what was the
first time you ever told anybody that
you worked for the CIA outside of your
family in other words in publicly well
after I retire I retire openly so when I
retire I could tell people they work
with the CIA
I requested when I retire which I was
proud to work for the CIA and I request
an open retirement which means I didn't
need any cover she sold my participation
with the agency in operation were
knowing to the host government where it
was they saw no reason anything I got an
open retirement so I legally can tell
people I retired from the AEC from 1976
on that's when I told people about it
are there things that you did for the
agency that you can't tell yes I think
they are saying they should not be told
for the same reason there are operations
that are still going on we're still
giving fruits and you could be revealed
it will completely destroy its value did
you have to have this book cleared by
the CIA yes I did were there things that
you had written that they took out it
was very leader the day to Kyle because
I made sure I didn't put anything that
would compromise people or operations so
there were some technical words that the
that we had no problem with we were very
closely together in reviewing the book
and there are a few things that that we
probably was a very valid every question
we took it out and all that that we
requested to keep it in and they saw
there was no need to take it out and we
were
and we got a clearance for the book John
Weisman how did the two of you work
together did you talk this through to
him
did you do it in a tape recorder did you
write or did well no we got together and
I used to talk to him about the
different experience and he will tape it
then then he will come back with - great
then we'll discuss it and he'll write it
and I they were seeing that the idæan
field were accurate that was hard to
project it that way until we finally got
it that I liked very much what came out
in the book who is John Weisman what's
his background well he's uh used to be
working for TV guy before he had written
several novels and I like him very much
personally and I think he's a fantastic
writer and to be interested in the book
and I think I'm not a very good book my
opinion did the two of you agree
politically it was that necessary I
don't think they would be necessary with
just a matter of putting my story in the
book truthfully as possible and as
accurate as possible and I think he have
done that where were you born I was born
in Cuba where I was born actually in
Havana but I claimed my hometown to be
Santa spirited was you see I was just
taken by love I couldn't save a mistake
but I was taking to Havana because I
came in a position that neither a more
specialized doctor so I was born in
Havana but I consider myself a spirit
one from Santa spirit way I was raised
more in 1941 1941 what were your parents
like oh we had a great life we had a
very close family in Cuba and my father
used to have a store that my grandfather
gave me and working there along with my
mother Santa spirit this must be yes and
we were one of these families that we
used to go and have for example New
Year's Eve we used to meet in my
grandmother's and all these songs and
daughter will get together there it was
a very very close family
what's this picture that's from my my
home my hometown that's my home in Santa
spirit where I was raised and in the
bottom is where my parents when they got
married and your parents Ally my mother
died my father still alive where does he
live
believe in Miami with us we
a big house sort of a condominium type
of my file it was me on the on the other
side what did he did for a living but he
had a historian Cuba and he used to have
a whole kind of to buy what he call it a
general store with special oppressions
and simply that he sell him there how
did you as a family leave Cuba well I
came to school back in 1953-54 to
Pennsylvania to go to high school so I
went to procurement preparatory school
until I finally graduated in 1960 and
what we used to living in Santa spirit
when I used to commute back and forth
and go back to took us about two three
times a year to visit them why did you
go to school in Pennsylvania
well my uncle offered me to go to school
and had another angle who convinced me
how important it was to have an
education outside to be able to speak
another language it will help me through
my life in the future I wanted actually
to be an architect an engineer like my
uncle's were but because of the queue
line I instead of going to the
University of Miami which I was accepted
I decided to go and fight for my country
what did you learn in Pennsylvania about
what your own interests were in
Pennsylvania when you went to school
there did you what did you begin to
think was going to be your interests and
and where did you go after school
well my lay interest when I went to high
school first there was the engineering
and architect but a sings turn at the
different cue back in 1959 Fidel took
over I concentrated my thought and to be
able to return to my country and that's
saying that the prevalent thing and now
I think it's my main objective in life
that's why I went to the training camps
in first of all in the Dominican
Republic that was the first action that
we had and it was not with the agency at
the time it was back in 1959 and then
later when the opportunity arrives to go
to Guatemala for later became the Bay of
Pigs invasion then I went there and
tried my best to go back to Europe where
did you get your dislike and I'm sure
that's a mild word for Fidel Castro can
you remember well when he started the
the firing squad and the assassination
plots before my family
told me that he was a communist and he
had the background that was not widely
publicized participating the Bogota in
Colombia many years before there was a
communist inspired situation and as he
progressing his regime and assassinated
people and indiscriminately put people
in jail they continued to create my
desire to create the democratic
government in Cuba which still is can
you remember when you had a sense that
you could assassinate him when did you
first feel strongly enough about this
that you could kill him but we were in
the training car we saw that there was
we were all preparing to go for the
invasion for enforcing there we thought
this would be like I said before an
opportunity to do shorten the war in
there instead of having a long term ward
it really mean a favela which was the
head of the revolution would probably be
easier for all the rest of the forces to
come in and seize power because che
guevara Che Guevara was one of the
member who landed with Fidel in Cuba
when he first went was here my certify
against Batista and we will know is a
well-known revolutionary who then left
you and went to Africa in 1965 and then
went to believe in 1966 at the end of
1966 where is he from Rosa Argentina
Argentina and it's something that you
take great pleasure in here in this book
telling the story about Che Guevara why
well it's not that I take it the very
pleasure is part of the history part
what I meant by that as you talked about
it being one of your most memorable
moments on the day that if you can tell
the story sure well for a long time he
of being one of our greatest adversaries
he was one of the people who headed the
LA cabaña fortress and who actually
assassinated thousands of Cubans in
there and when I was told by the agency
in 1967 that he was in Bolivia would I
participate after they talked to me I
thought it was a fantastic challenge to
go there and try to roll back what he
was trying to do in Central America the
same thing that had happened in Cuba how
did he die well when I write to you by
the way these pictures of the two of you
right here right that's that's the only
picture ever of commander Guevara
you have never been made public until
this year everybody thought probably
never existed that's why I believe they
recently they called the giving
intersection we said that their official
version of shares that was that he died
in combat how did this picture then
become public
well I had the pictures and finally now
a lot of people convinced they should
release it with the book it would be
interesting to people and also tell the
story of how it happened because a lot
of people have claims from
different-sized how Che Guevara died you
take a version from the far right take a
version from the far left
they are 180 degrees apart and I thought
for the benefit of history that the
story should be told the way happened
without taking part for historical
purpose how did it happen well I guess
it was definitely one of the highlight
of my life situation that I did face in
Bolivia which I hope I don't have to
face again but for example we we went
there as an advisor to the 2nd Ranger
Battalion who was the battalion under
the 8th division that was operating the
area where he was let me stop you to
saying this was in what year 1967 and
you were working for the agency right
assigned to Bolivia right assigned to
work with the government of Bolivia and
one of the reasons that they choose me
and my friend another Cuban was that we
were not US citizen at the time and
there was a prohibition by the US
ambassador in Bolivia that no non-us
citizen could go but no US citizen could
participate in the operational area
avoiding a conflict so I had not the
limitation because I was not a citizen
so I was able to accompany the the units
are being in real conflicting areas in
the area and go ahead and tell the story
okay when I first got there we work
closely first at the investor answer
with the 2nd Ranger Battalion my friend
concentrated mostly in training what we
call the eyes and ears of the battalion
that was a specialized unit of people
who spoke the Quechua and the Aymara
farmers from the area that were just
turned into soldiers and they were to go
in civilian clothes when the battalion
were to be deployed to
able to talk to the farmers and get the
information to feed the intelligence to
the battalion at the same time I
concentrated mostly in operating at the
division level with Colonel Santana who
was later assassinated in Paris by the
so called commander Che Guevara a being
ambassador of Bolivia in France and I
was an advisor to the colonel and to his
head of intelligence at the time so
we're able to track all the movement of
J and I used to accompany the head of
intelligence to whenever the reversing
encounter with the guerrillas by other
units Bolivian units for example we were
able to to keep alive
Paco jose castillo chavez who i
interrogated and gave us the in-depth
intelligence on how shares group
operated with the Bhangarh center and
rear guard because of his intelligence
we were able to determine when
lieutenant Galindo had an encounter and
killed three gorillas one of them was a
Cuban by the name of Miguel the other
one was a Bolivian dr. Cole Mario Theory
hard ayah and another Bolivian leader
called croc operator we knew from Pacwa
these weren't three forward element of
Che and the che was in the area so with
this information was able to go back to
Colonel Santino and recommend that the
training should be cut short of the
battalion that was being specially
trained by the US Special Forces so he
called two weeks out of the Train that
had to be free just for graduation
purposes and move the battalion into the
area at the varying of September I guess
it's also a gray element of luck that
done the 7th of October the intelligence
unit that we had trained on my frame
actually had trained had conversation
with campesinos of farmers in the area
who told him that they were voices at
the Cabrera lecture where nobody
supposed to be so he passes information
to the captain of the company that was
operating away in the area from this
battalion and they put a Cirque
surrounded around at a specific area on
the evening of the 7th of October
on the 8th when they first started to
move they had the first encounter with
the guerrilla they were able to capture
a commander Guevara live with another
bolivian called
Simone Cuba's warning was Willie and and
at that point I was actually setting up
communication gear in airplanes into
well now there are very old
single-engine playing that the believing
had had no communication with the ground
troops so I took the time to put the
antennas and to put a PRC turn radio
that was compatible to have a compatible
communication from the air to the ground
so when that arrived and they were still
not clear you can imagine what sensation
of not only happiness but it is hard to
explain that probably Guevara was
captured and nobody could really believe
it so I got into the back seat of one of
the plane and Mayor Surratt into the
back of the other one we flew over the
area and we confirmed a West what they
call Papa with the leader of the
guerrilla Council and in they say
Elektra here which is the foreigner so
we knew they were [ __ ] we returned it
from there and that evening we gather at
the at the hotel in valle grande and i
asked colonel Santino a1 at the company
you spoke to his people in there and
told them that how much we had helped
them and if they didn't mind he knew how
much it meant to me to be face to face
with my enemy for many many years so he
agreed and everybody agree in the area
and on the following day we flew up
seven o'clock the morning on a small
helicopter the pilot was mayor Hyman
Amelie Guzman Colonel Centeno myself
into llegará we first came in and we
land the right beside the schoolhouse
where he was and Colonel Centeno and
another officer and myself going to the
room yes if you question from Shea and
he will look at he and not answer so he
left the area and went back to the
operational area where still you could
hear the fighting going on we are still
shooting less than a kilometer from
there with the rest of the guerrilla was
in the general area so I set up my sort
of a shop leader photography area there
to photograph the diary and all the
document that he had with him so I asked
her know Santino he made available to me
his bag where he had all the documents
and everything and once in a while going
and the first time I came in I look at
him and he was tied down it was an
emotional moment to see this man that I
have seen before his day of glory
Moscow and China and now I saw this man
in the floor in rags destroyed beaten
and front of him were the dead body of
two Cubans that were very close to him
so I look at him I say Che Guevara I'd
like to talk to you he looked at me very
arrogantly and said nobody interrelates
me I wish I look back and say look I
didn't come here to thoroughly use there
were ideals are different by admire you
used to be a head of a stain queue and
you are like this because you believe in
your idea I just came to talk to you we
look to me for about a minute or so and
so if I was sincere so then he said can
I see it can you untie me I say sure I
order one of the soldiers in there to
come in untie him and we said leaning a
little bench he asked for some tobacco
for his pipe so I got a cigarette from
one of the soldier mr. Mogan his pipe
and we had a conversation on and off
because I had to continue to first of
all say a message by review and also
radio operator by telegraphy to
headquarters in Washington now he
already prepared the day before at the
same time finished photographing the
diary so I came in several times there
was one point in time with the
helicopter arrived that had left to take
out our wounded were killed and bring
back food and ammunition and the major
Neeley was man brought a camera to take
a picture of the prisoner and I had my
camera I didn't even thought of that at
the time so I asked him do you mind and
commander and say no so we took him
aside and the picture are looking at and
after that when I was still there and
Colonel Santana were still out in the
field we got a phone call from vagrant
it's only one telephone Eli Guerra which
is the small village where he was and
that phone call brought the instruction
from the high command of the Bolivian
government to eliminate the prison so
when Colonel Centeno came down I was the
highest-ranking officer at the time had
the rank of captain in the area and
there was only lieutenant they get us so
they called me a to be phone call so I
went when Colonel Centeno returned it to
leave I call him aside and I told him
there was instruction from his high
command to eliminate the prisoner my
instruction from the US government was
to try to keep him alive but we should
say look we know you have tried to have
helped us a great deal but this is
from a high command you can eliminate
any way you want and we know how much
harm you have done to your country but I
want your word of honor that you will
bring me back the dead body of Che
Guevara two o'clock in the afternoon
that was one the middle in the morning
so I told him I'll try to change their
mind but it's my instruction but if
there is not any other instruction from
you I'll give you my word of honor that
will bring you back the dead body of Che
Guevara if I continued to talk to him
back and forth and in there until one
time I left the room and the
schoolteacher girl lady came to me and
saved me Capitan why are you going to
kill him I say lady were you saying that
they say well we have seen you in their
photograph with him and she brought a
small portable reagan said here is the
rare saying that he had died from combat
wounds already so at that point I
thought it was not much point continuing
to wait it was after 12:30 noontime I
went into the room when he was sitting I
look at him and say commander I'm sorry
these are order from the I believe in
command he turned white by a piece of
paper and everything anybody lose the
color of his face like he did but he
didn't move a muscle you look at
Ministry and say Felix is better this
way as you had never been capture alive
to pull out the Pythons I'd like to give
this pipe to assaulted ito small soldier
who treated me well and at that point in
time sergeant ER I'm broke into the room
and say you go look here I wanted you
know I want che had the pipe assigned
say no I won't give it to you so I order
twice for him to leave until he finally
the room he he work with the pipe like
this and say commander will you give it
to me so we thought for a while and say
yes at this Attila would mean yes up to
you I will give you gave me the pipe
I put her weight and then idea I told
him is there anything you want for your
family so he look at me and I you could
detect very easily was a lot of sadness
and sarcastic in his voice when he said
tell Fidel that he will soon see a
triumphant revolution in America then he
Shane and say and tell my wife to
remarry and try to be happy
so we shook hand we embrace it was
definitely very emotional moment that
never in my life have being a seat
issue had to tell Samba is going to be
killed I hope they don't have to go
through that again and after that I let
it ruin 18 when he stood in attention
the ballet he thought maybe I was going
to be the one killing him I really
didn't one even to be there I left the
room I called sergeant Aaron who I knew
was doing that in there and say sorry
and don't should tear down this man
supposed to die from combat one from
here up here from here down and I let
the room it was one o'clock in the
afternoon about 110 I was right beside
the table I had set up to take up the
pictures I heard the fire so I look at
my watch and it took know that it was
one thing when he died surprised how
compassionate you were with him at that
point
at that point in time you really cannot
he sees exactly what happened you know a
lot of people sometimes have criticized
me for it but it's something at that
point in time you cannot control is the
way it happened I guess as an enemy I
respected the man who died with dignity
and he was very very dangerous because
you strongly believe he is ideal even
though it were wrong but that's I can
tell you that the exact version of how
he died because you will find when you
read a lot of papers like I say from
both sides completely different
attitudes what did you do then with the
body well after a while two captains
came from the Bolivian and we are
winning after they left there I wash his
face that had mud on the face and
getting on the helicopter on the Ryosuke
of the helicopter and we were ready to
leave the there is a soldier who came
and told the pilot mingler was lying can
you wait by the shieler wants to see him
and here comes a priest on a meal that
almost got decapitated because he was
just so intensely looking at the body
that we can see that the the blade of
the shopper was already going on and he
stopped just about this close from the
blade and he went down he actually
blessed which to me not looking inside I
took a picture while he was doing that
and I mentally went over and said this
is a man that
believe in God nevertheless he received
life right ritual of the church we took
off from there and we learned that value
around the area and that's where they
were waiting for us everybody sort of
took my cap down I was in uniform and
left so I would be you know out of a big
picture of photographed whatever and of
course everybody left with the body to
the hospital mattress annually Malta
where he was attended there and I stay
with the head of intelligence major
subset and the head of operation Sara
Otte and the pilot and the wing had the
meeting with general obonda who was the
commander-in-chief of the Armed Forces
this is the book we're talking about and
the author is Felix Rodriguez along with
John Weisman Shadow Warrior is the title
how you remember all this well this
first of all is varying things is
something that is hard for you to read
from your mind secondly had to brief a
lot of people at my first briefing of
course was the my case officer in
Bolivia they have to give the same story
to general Porter in Panama and other
people so it's something that is not
very easy to forget here's some more
photographs from the book and including
what is a over here is a picture of John
Kerry senator from Massachusetts Senator
sarbanes next to him George Bush
surprised United States and yours truly
when was this taken that was taking on
May the 1st 1986 and why were you there
with the vice president well I had many
vice president first of all the first
time was in January
Don Gregg introduced me to he knew I was
going to a Salvador for the helicopter
concept and I briefing on the helicopter
concept and also show him an album that
I had with the capture of Che Guevara so
the second time I went to visit him at
that point I was planning to leave of
Salvador I want to show the audience
also this note we've seen we've heard a
lot about the presidential notes and
this was from October 23rd 1988 right
they send the president-elect at the
time a Christmas car he
nice enough to last for me with another
car and he says in here yes the truth is
powerful you have told the truth
why was he writing to you about truth
what we hope of being so much because I
believe monthly the political situation
trying to implicate that he knew more
about those things and we always believe
that the truth is powerful and will
eventually prevail so he was telling me
that from and all that it did prevail
the truth you went turns inaugural why
oh I am very proud of being there I
admire the President of the United
States and I've know better than anybody
else his truthfulness and his integrity
they have been put in question by a lot
of people for political reasons how do
you know better than anybody else
because everybody accused that I talking
about the country and I know that I
never mentioned to him or don't Greg
anything about the country and this all
came out in the hearings oh yes what do
you think of it here well I'll tell you
why I went to the hearings a lot of
people told me to bring a lawyer in my
house including and I thought that it
would be odd for me I believe in this
country that I will need a lawyer to
defend what I have been doing for the
last 27 years at that point in time to
defend the United Stated a lawyer to
defend that and I was in the wrong
country and I don't believe I am in the
wrong country when the truth of yourself
when did you testify testifying the 27
on the 28th of May 1987 before what
committee or the rank country Committee
and why were you called I was called
because I was I participated in the
resupply of the contra by providing in
El Salvador the contacts to be able to
launch the operation from there for
resupply of the Contras actually and you
also testify before senator Kerry's
committee yes that's another one of the
motive I wrote the book after all the
testimony in Congress he used a man
called Ramon me Leon Rodriguez to imply
the knowledge of the vice president then
I had received a million dollar of drug
money for the Contras from me and
Rodriguez and he had proven it was an
absolute lie I did talk to him once at
the request of a lieutenant who said the
million Rodriguez could compromise the
government of Nicaragua
he was asking a tape of an assisting of
Daniel Ortega from Guatemala to set up a
laundering money operation out of Panama
for the benefit of the Nicaraguan
government I went and hear him out and
as soon as I finished the meeting with
me Leon Rodriguez I passed the
information to the FBI and when I came
to wash it on a path the information to
be CIA and ever since I never even
talked to the guy again my life I'm
Kerry you this individual who had been
put in jail for forty six years into
promoting the idea that I the vice
president knew about it and authorized
this type of an operation I was involved
in getting the money for the country
actually was in El Salvador flying at
the time when my wife called me and told
me there was a story in Miami Carol's
saying about that which I told her
forget about it you know it is nothing
true to it but she was very concerned
that people doesn't know us and they
read this in the paper and is very
detrimental to you to your family and
your integrity so I did go and testify
in private with Senator Kerry it was a
very strong hearing and they didn't want
to do it in an open hearing at the time
and then it took me
well over a year to testify openly and
one day they wish I hope that c-span
could cover it because he made sure that
c-span did cover the hearing with me
Leon Rodriguez and I specifically
requested from Kathleen Smith and Jack
Blum from his committee that I wanted to
testify with c-span coverage and they
say oh yeah this is going to be a lot of
coverage when I arrived there they put
me like the number five to testify it
was 4:30 in the afternoon there was no
television camera to cover my testimony
I mean that hearing he had to admit that
he believed me that it wasn't true then
I led later learn because he didn't even
set at the time that they have wrong a
lie detector test of me Leon Rodriguez
and he proved that the two crucial
questions that he had they asked about
me that were he was lying on the third
one he decided not to continue with the
lie detector test you mean we weren't
there when you came to testify closer no
one was there no television they were
right there was a camera but it wasn't
error anywhere and I specifically
requested they would be cameras in there
but I guess when he have for so long
it's amazing the millions of dollars he
is paying of taxpayer morning
investigation trying to prove that the
country were involved in drug and then
when doesn't come out you know you just
let it go right and then when I tried
for him to put this in television let
the people know it was a it was sort of
Pooja sorry what well so the audience
understand we don't Senator Kerry
doesn't tell c-span when to carry his
hearings and vice versa the point though
it's interesting because we carried most
of those hearings and I'm interested to
hear that you say we weren't there what
day of the week was it well I forgot
what day was but for example they had
this day they had a meal Murphy in it
well he had me like number five witness
that they started a o'clock in the
morning and I o'clock in the morning and
my hearing was about 4:30 in the
afternoon so a that time even the
reporters were going out of the room but
if we were there in the beginning we
were there in the end as he only could
we stay from the beginning then they
somehow the shoes a day that you were
not there what day the week was this a
Friday
I forgot we do it what they was Jack
Blum you here's a page 256 Jack Blom's
Olympus reaction you feel strongly about
Jack one yes who is it I don't like the
way he's a lawyer that apparently came
out out of the Institute for policy that
had by ambassador of light which
everybody knows a very liberal
individual and actually didn't realize
at the time that they were the one who
got Harry involved in this
this investigation is the group from
ambassador white bastard white used to
be the ambassador to El Salvador El
Salvador the at the end of Jimmy
Carter's presidency and Jack Gramm
worked for him he was a member of
trustee of the board of trustee of the
Jack Blum's
of excuse me of ambassador white
organization it was fascinating when you
see the relationship between Jack blonde
carries committee the Christic Institute
it was recently thrown out of court all
the thing that they did with that
completely raised a claim of
assassination teams and the
assassination of a tempest Ora
troll you're familiar with the lasted
for over a year until finally George
King threw it out of court in the Miami
area
and they make people spend millions of
dollars in it and they were trying to
accuse and then you got the Christian
Institute giving credibility to the
investigation because it said a Senate
subcommittee is and it's always the same
people who got Jack Blow involved
senator Kerry's committee the Christic
Institute and they were all the same
thing brenneke is one of the sources all
of them use the proof to be a liar and
it's amazing so one of the reasons you
wrote this book was because you didn't
get coverage all during that period that
you thought you deserved to tell your
story
yes it's very hard when they accuse you
of narcotics being involved in narcotics
not being true and you see a publicized
newspaper laying in salvador in
guatemala all over the united states and
then when the senators say they believe
you it doesn't appear anywhere and did
senator kerry eventually say he believed
you oh yes he said in the in the open
hearing but there was no television
coverage there and i do have the
transcript from the senate that said
that exactly the same thing plus it
added the fact that memory was proved to
be a liar in the lie detector test what
impact did it have on your life in miami
and with your family once your story
started becoming public
prior to this book in other words it
have a negative impact on the family
your wife's call relief it believed in a
community that is very sympathetic to
the for anything that had to do against
communism but nevertheless i was people
who doesn't know me people who knows me
it doesn't bother me at all because they
know exactly what I have done and where
I stand but people who listen know you
and they get the style allegation from a
congressional committee is very
disturbing chapter 18 I learned
sometimes painfully in the weeks and
months following my initial Capitol Hill
testimony that people tend to deal not
in the truth as it really is but the
truth as they want to see it and the
facts be damned and you go on to talk
about the press and in in some detail
you say in my own case I found scores of
repertory Allaire errs of fact some
might be considered minor but taken as a
body of work they led me to the
inescapable conclusion that too many
journalists just don't care very much
either about the facts or telling the
truth and then you go on to give
examples tell us some of the exam
oh we had for example reports of the an
organization all in the Rolling Stone
piece the rolling stone that make the
same echo of the carry committee an
operation they invented called
black eagle and they claim that all of
these people were involved I was
involved in operation before North
organization in supporting the country
whose never existed that's the story
where they used the de Grasse Israeli
operation so in support of the contra
before Oliver North's they had met for
example general goo steel and back in
1983 in El Salvador for this operation
they were story for example that I cite
in there which fortunately was killed I
would say for example in ABC where they
had brenneke getting the same player of
Courage Committee saying that I was in
Panama telling pilots that don't worry
about it that device pressing is
supporting this operation 100% it was an
operation allegedly for drugs and and
resupply of the country which never
existed and I challenged and I said look
tell me what they did was well they
couldn't come up with the exact date
they tell me within two weeks because
the amount that they said that I was
doing that in Panama I flew extensively
with the Salvadoran air force against
the guerrilla and 99% of the chances
were that the day that they will picked
up it would be able to tell them the
what operation I was who was my co-pilot
detail of my helicopter and the result
of the operation so when the other
source that they had could not give any
of this detail that the eventually
killed his horse but there was a lot of
these misinformation all over brenneke
is that Richard brenneke right who is he
I don't know I have read later on that
he was a I believe a businessman from
Oregon who claimed that he worked for
the CIA he claimed that he worked for
the UH for the Israeli I believe he's
under indictment right now for lying he
portraying a federal agent I say he used
to work for the CIA
produce a fake document from the agency
who is a Jose blonde on what a never
knew of him until I saw it in one of the
tables I think was either senator curry
or Leslie Cogburn with the same group
that manipulated all of his operation
and he claimed at one point in time
she's put was put out of context I
remember seeing a tape from him saying
yes Felix Rodriguez was the one that
well I saw him the first time on
television because I'd never met him in
my life
that's Jose Blondin and who is he well I
read that he was invited to Noriega in
telling advice Connery at one point in
time he this is a few weeks ago the day
of the attempted Panamanian coup against
general Noriega he is standing in the
Senate
ready on television gallery and you'll
see in just a moment that there are
senators from both sides of political
fence senator Helms the conservative
side senator Kerry on the liberal side
and others including senator D'Amato is
here in your opinion a reliable witness
well CIA even though because I don't
know him because when he was put in
context what happened the way I saw him
there was he they were trying to portray
his operation and never existed all
right that I was working with these
rally to supply the contract before
North's operation and then they shine
blam don't say and yes there was a man
in salvador called Felix Rodriguez who
was helping the resupply of the country
now he was referring to the time was
Oliver North and he was correct if he
was referring to a time that never
existed before of course he was lying
but I don't know whether he was used in
that context or not you wrote in your
book from my experience only witnesses
whose views were ideologically opposed
to Kerry's and lumps anti contra policy
were questioned aggressively one of
Carey's fellow senators Republican Mitch
McConnell privately wrote the
Massachusetts Democrat that
investigation was turning into a
witch-hunt
Senator McConnell helped you in this
process well they went to he and totally
when they when he was in the committee
was Kerry and I wanted to testify ugly
and Kerry would not have me to testify
after I saw me Leon Rodriguez testimony
on television so he held me in trying to
get Kerry to have an open hearing with
me and for a long time he didn't so he
provided they a press conference in the
Senate where everybody was including
most of the network and they film it and
he was never aired I even brought a
paper to senator Kerry saying that is
obviously from the testimony of million
Rodriguez myself that wanted to his lyin
I wanted the committee to pursue it to
the very end give the full strength of
the law to that one which is lying who
was committing perjury and I signed that
I put that under with my uncle with a
affidavit to them to the committee to
make sure that where was lying the two
of us would be prosecuted to the maximum
extent of the law I don't know whatever
happened to that document because he
gave satisfaction to me by a given guest
I guess they never give an additional
sentence two million or maybe they were
afraid that medium will come back and
say that they promised him some leniency
by lying how many interviews have you
given so far on your book like this is
just how long have you been on are you
on a tour yes it's about 3 or 3 days to
her what's the reaction I think they've
been very positive are you getting an
opportunity to tell your side of the
story most of the places yes when they
people disagree with you strongly what
is it over at this stage what is that
what do people strongly disagree with
you about in your tour at this point
have you done radio call-in shows and
things like that where people react are
people you get a lot of opposition to
your point of view no as a matter of
fact had the two radio shows in New York
and the one the hot coals in call there
was not a single negative coat they were
all very positive why do you think that
you had such a rough time here in this
city with the committee's mainly was a
political year in my opinion it was very
important for them not the truth but the
perception and I think that's what
carries committee pursued to the very
end the perception of the American
people are depressing and the device
pressing and then was lying to see will
probably generate some vote for the
Democratic side when the the election
was over than the de línea aside what do
you think of Oliver North I met I really
are not the cannot talk with that
authority about him I didn't know him
that well when I first met him I liked
him very much
his idea were very much along with mine
very positive and he's recorded my going
to a Salvador Peru helicopter come said
very very much very very good
nevertheless I guess for him
to be involved in that many thing that
he was involved with kind of hard and it
was almost impossible to really master
15 or 20 different operation where he
had his hand on you do right though that
when you visited him in his office that
he said some things about you that
weren't true right
what were those well I talked to him he
accused me I was talking openly on the
telephone line that was a security
reason I asked him to prove it he told
me that he could not because those were
under the Freedom of Information Act
they could not give it to me and less
you know I guess I will sign for an L
told him I said look I'll sign to your
release from the CIA FBI NSC whatever
you want but proof to me they are a
security risk and he never came up with
any not document to substantiate what he
have said but I believe to a great
extent that he was led by other people
who I was critical of because of the
poor equipment that was being used in
the resupply operation and God knows all
the things that they were telling him at
the time he wrote one is that North had
grandiose ideas about himself what do
you mean well I was one time for example
sitting in his office and he received a
phone call from somebody and he said in
the telephone I have in front of me my
sheave of operation in Central America
and there was the time that I just
started to work with him and there was
no no social organizations achieve of
operation with Central America for him I
was just helping implementing the help
of the Nicaraguan resistent was boo Shia
strongly supported he also had the habit
of telling people that I had been
recruited by him indeed he would make a
point of keeping my old friend Don Gregg
in the dark when it came to my
participation in his covert contra
operations why perhaps because Don would
not have approved the way he was going
about it Donald Gregg current ambassador
to Korea he's your friend yes he is
used to be a top aide to current
President George Bush then vice
president right why are you friends with
Don Gregg will we go back to Vietnam
back in 1970 71 or 72 but Don Gregg was
the regional chief in the area near
Saigon Benoit
where I was working with the PRU the
provincial reconnaissance unit that's
where I work
the concept that was later very
effective in on salvador so the dog was
my boss at that point in time and he
knew of the success of the operation in
vietnam and we continue the friendship
and relationship all through this year
and we still are very close friends what
do you like about Don Greg he's a very
straight individual he's a very honest
individual and he's going to business
people who knows him can tell you that
he's a fantastic guy for example a very
straight individual all of these
publicized memorandum that came out in
the iran-contra later on the question
because he said that there was resupply
of the Contra to be discussed which was
never discussed he was the one who found
it and he was the one who turned her
over to the committees another of
North's qualities was naive tech what do
you say that in your book I don't think
he was that much knowledgeable a lot of
these operation and paramilitary
activities that he was involved and
that's perhaps he was misguided to a
great extent and it I know he's really
background in paramilitary operation but
what we were doing in Central American
resupply and that operation when he got
his people in I don't think they really
knew that much about it it was the last
time you're in combat of any kind or any
kind of skirmish Oh early this year I
was flying in the Salvador as a matter
of fact that's when we did one program
television program 60 minutes and Mike
Wallace was one one of the helicopters
and we even took fire that time we have
one pilot not pilot once all your
killing one of our helicopter and the
other one badly wounded are you on call
to do more work like this if they want
it I always say I think I will continue
after this this tour to to flying
Salvador as long as there is great
communist guerrillas in that area taking
any chances of writing this book in the
middle of possibility you might do more
work for the CIA no I like finish
working for the CIA 1976 and I believe
from the exposition I don't think the
but if there is an opportunity that I
can have it would certainly be available
but I doubt very much that they would
call upon me who you work for then if
you go
and El Salvador no in the work for
anybody volunteer my service as an
individual to help the Salvadorian since
I got my retirement I don't need the pay
from anybody and they gave me a place to
sleep and to eat in the airbase in there
so I just got my own retribution from my
feeling they are still contributing
something worthwhile they have not
abandoned the fight I started in 1961
when the Bay of Pigs that I have not
abandoned the people who died in that
time and my committee my guess will more
or less be finished when Q is free q is
not yet free thank you will ever be free
in your lifetime I am very convinced
over they will be they probably sooner
than a lot of people expected if
somebody came to you today and said
Felix we've got another mission for you
we want you to go assassinate Fidel
Castro would you do it I don't think
this problem is done there is a
situation of assassination will solve a
problem down there I think there is
going to take care by itself the
political internal situation in there
and I feel very strongly a perhaps in
the next two years we will see a free
Cuba or at least a tremendous change
from the present political situation
I mean heading toward a democracy that
will eventually become one what do you
think of Daniel Ortega especially have
been reading lately about what here
being cancelled this is fire I hope that
they will go through with the election
and I hope that they can really be
honest about it and then take the
consequences themselves of the result of
the election I believe that lately I was
reading that the polls show that the
Violeta Chamorro have a choir heading
over Daniel Ortega and perhaps is trying
to see how he can get away from that
election obviously in the past we didn't
have the support the US Congress 100% so
I think it's important to give an
opportunity to this election and to this
initiative in Central America but at the
same time believe is very important that
if it doesn't work we have a very closed
Congress working with the President of
the United States make sure that we do
work together to create free democracies
in that part of the world you've seen a
lot of revolutionaries what do you think
of Daniel Ortega as a revolutionary gee
tough Daniel Tiger is the is the
creation of Fidel Castro my opinion and
he responds a great deal to feel
and Fidel support in that part of the
the air in his country
I don't believe you have the popular
support of the people and I believe that
they are free elections in there that it
definitely you later Samara will win and
then remain to be seen where they will
turn over the reins of power to a
democracy you write in your book page
235 few US congressman in fact have
taken adequate time to personally
examine the problems in El Salvador it
is far more pleasant for them to travel
on fact-finding trips to Paris Rome and
London and when they do visit this
country they all too often arrive for
only a few hours with their minds made
up already they are prepared to support
only those issues they've set into their
own personal agendas fair criticism you
find a lot of the the congressmen that
going down there they have the do not
agree with Salvador they go and visit
the same people from the left in
Salvador that will tell them what they
want to hear most of them really doesn't
go to the countryside tried to go on and
go to the hospital I don't say all I say
a lot of things don't go in to the
hospital and see really the dimension of
the Communist minds are doing on the
soldiers on civilian in the area and you
got a lot of problems that they will
take they will take for example you know
not only that they will they will see if
I can get it putting work regularly a
lot of time when they have problem with
the administration they take action
which are not what they are singing
there for example we see when the
congressman Oh be caught the resupply of
the helicopter huge 512 Salvador he was
having a problem thing with the
administration and the 500 was the
helicopter I was using to fly treetop
level to make sure that there was no
civilian casualties because it the only
helicopter at that altitude that can
determine civilians from from military
or guerrilla troops you suggest in your
book that congressman Toby was
responsible for some El Salvador and
death well if you look from their
perspective he at one point in time
turned down the resupply of 500
helicopter into the area which was
vitally to be used for actually
the gorilla before and that was one of
the problem that we had in there is when
there is a contacting area and they
tried to bomb a place if you don't have
an eyeball to eyeball contact which then
you may be to 300 meter off and very
heavily populated the country you might
hit the wrong people so the 500 is
actually the helicopter will determine
the exact location of the guerrilla and
eliminate the civilian casualties and
because he got problem with the
administration he hold on delivering
five huge 500 helicopter he took a long
time to the Ambassador and to the head
of the mill group to finally convince
him to release it one at a time you only
have about two minutes left and I want
to show the audience a couple of things
and we're going to have to ask mark on
this camera to do that on your left
lapel is a couple of buttons there one
of them looks like some kind of a combat
ribbon and the other one looks like
explain to us and we'll get on the
screen here in just a second okay what
are those two this one on top is the the
CIA intelligence Star for valor and then
the bottom one is the is the button for
the Veterans of Foreign Wars okay right
and then you have a tie clasp on that I
want the audience to see and ask you
what that says from here it looks like
it says George Bush does it yes it is
the detective the the name Vice
President Bush gave me the first time
that I visit his office in January of
1985 and I'm very proud of it and to
wear it this is the book and it's
written by